[Music]
Tyree starts off this hour in Baltimore
Maryland hey Tyree how are you hey how
you doing today Dave take my car
certainly sir how can I help we we're
new listeners we make I just became a
truck driver about a year ago we make
about 70 thousand a year we have about
we have a household of six my fiance is
in school to be an RN she has about two
years left we have two cars one of them
is Prague's and one arms on his last leg
we pay about 1350 of money in rent we
really want to buy a house but we don't
know how to get started we still living
check to check and something's not going
right we don't know what you mean about
loading up your phone one we just
started that and I have about ninety six
hundred dollars in debt from a car repo
so I really don't know what to do from
here it's like we make a decent amount
of money so far and it's not working for
us and we have zero savings you know
what do you what do you make now is your
truck driver right now I make about
seventy thousand I'm scheduled to make
about 70 to 80 this year are you over
the road or in town
no I'm local okay good and so you've got
four kids yes okay and went out you and
your right when are you and your
feelings are getting married that's the
question we would have we want to get
married today but yeah she has about
twenty thousand in debt and I have only
ninety-six we try to see this smarter
they get married now or wait till we buy
a house or what should we do it doesn't
it doesn't change anything except makes
it everything you're doing much easier
from a legal standpoint when you're
married you should not buy a house until
you get these messes cleaned up you need
to get you a decent car or two we've got
to get your debts paid off and we need
to build an emergency fund no you don't
need to be investing in your 401 K right
now let me back up a couple steps okay
what we teach Tyrese is a program called
the baby steps and I've done it for 30
years with people and I did it myself
and it works
okay in other words what what step to
take first what step to take second what
step to take third and so on the very
first thing I want you to do is stop all
investing and get on a written budget in
detail go to every dollar com download
the app for your phone and or for your
desktop computer and you and your fiance
sit down and do that you don't have to
be debt free to get married you don't
have to buy a house to get married you
got four kids you might as well get
married yes there's no difference okay
you're acting like you're married every
way but legally exactly so you might as
well so if I were in your shoes that's
what I would do what are you 20 are you
32 we are I am 36 and she is 29 okay
almost like I've done this before okay
yeah that's where you're sitting and so
you know it's time to kind of wrap this
decade of your 20s up and move on into
the rest of the way into adulthood and
let's formalize this put together a
family unit where your grandma smiling
okay and we get you know so number one I
would go ahead and get married there's
nothing holding you back on that get a
written plan going on your budget when
does she graduate and get her r-n in
2020 okay good all right so it's gonna
be a little while is she working while
she's studying no not right now she just
we just found out that she's pregnant
okay with your fifth yes so that's a
real that's another really good reason
to get married then okay okay so anyway
the and how is she paying for nursing
school I see that she has student loans
that's the $20,000 in student loans so
far yes okay
all right so baby step number one once
we've gotten you on a budget in detail
we've stopped all investing we're
squeeze every dollar out of this budget
and make every dollar behave and work
towards your long-term goals now one of
the things you learn about money Island
this from rich people because I didn't
grow up a rich did you grow up rich not
at all okay so I had to learn from rich
people how to handle money and one of
the things I learned is is they are not
afraid to delay pleasure to win every
decision they make with money they think
about the long-term consequences so it
sounds like they don't have as much fun
but buddy when they have fun they have
big fun in other words you you pay a
price you live like no one else you you
buckle down you you know you coupon you
work extra jobs you don't go out to eat
and you don't do what feels good right
now you live like no one else so that
later though baby you can live and give
like no one else and you can change your
family tree these kids could be left
wealthy you're only in your 30s you can
still build you can still become a
millionaire before you pass easily
easily but you're gonna have to get
control and I'm going to show you how
baby step one the first thing you do
when you buckle everything down is you
save $1,000 once you've saved $1,000
then stop saving then we're gonna list
your debts smallest debt to largest debt
now your smallest debt is your ninety
six hundred then largest ones the twenty
two thousand are they any other debts
not at all good okay let's keep these
old broken cars running for a while and
limp along with them for right now
they're their basic transportation
they're bad we don't want to live like
this we're going to drive like no one
else so later we can drive like no one
else okay so let's keep those things
running get that emergency fund in place
then let's pay off these two debts
that's thirty thousand bucks get you out
of debt yes and you make a hundred
because now you work extra all right
here we go it's game on man all right so
we're gonna pay off thirty that's going
to take you with with five kids and they
went on the way it's gonna take you over
a year
it's not gonna take you ten years but
I'm talking beans and rice rice and
beans you have no freaking life all you
do is work and pay debt all she does is
work feed babies and pay debt that's all
we do we're getting this debt going
because if you want to be payments all
of a sudden you got some wiggle room in
this budget and then you can start you
build your emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then you save
up and buy you a little better car or
two because you do need to move up in
car after you built your emergency fund
see after you're out of debt then you
accept your house oh you know you don't
have a house yet we're gonna save up and
do that later okay and you think we've
had too much in rent probably but you
are in Baltimore it's pretty expensive
there if you can get something cheaper
it you know rent it's just patients rent
is camping we're just doing this for now
till we can get the money saved to buy a
house and the one we pay in rent the
less happen the longer it's gonna take
for us to buy a house and get out of
debt so hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover you read that book do every
single thing it says and you'll be all
right my man thank you for calling